wortschatz winter deutsch lernen mit
spaß
es schneit
der schnee
der schal die handschuhe
der schnee plus
der mann gleich
der schneemann
die hand plus
der schuh gleich der handschuh
die schuhe
die handschuhe
die skibrille die mütze die winterjacke
die skischuhe
die berge der sessellift der wald
der snowboarder
der skifahrer die skifahrerin
die winterlandschaft das eis das chalet
die schneeflocke
die schnee
flocken
der berg die berge
die skipiste
das snowboard
snowboardfahren
der ski die hier der skistock die
skistöcke skifahren
der schlitten
schlitteln
die tanne die tannen
es ist kalt
das eis
frieren